ANKUR KOTWAL: Hi, I'm Ankur
Kotwal, and I'm an engineer on
the Android Developer
Relations team
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Hi, I'm
Chris Broadfoot.
I work on the Google Maps
Android API team.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Today we're going
to talk to you about the
Maps API for Android.
And we're going to cover
a few things.
But to start with, let's
talk about animation.
If you have a look at the sample
code for the Maps API,
you'll see that we use handlers
to animate markers
and for other purposes, too.
So what we're going to talk
about today is how you can use
handlers for backward
compatibility but use some of
the newer APIs, ie the property
animation framework,
to have an even better
experience.
So let's switch to the tablet,
and let's just see a basic
marker animating.
All we're doing is where we
tap, we just generate a
polyline from the source
to destination.
Just tell the marker
to move there.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yup.
ANKUR KOTWAL: So here,
we've accomplished
what we wanted to.
But as I said in Gingerbread and
older, what we would do is
animate the marker's position
using a handler.
So let's have a look at
some code that shows
us how we do this.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: OK, so we'll
be showing you three ways of
animating a marker.
And each of these methods will
have the same parameters--
so the marker itself, the final
destination lat long, so
that's its final point, and a
lat long interpolator, which
we'll talk about a
little bit later.
So from Gingerbread and before,
we need to do a little
bit of setup to set up our
animation handler.
So first of all, we get the
start position just by calling
get position on the marker.
And then again, some of that's
set up, so just the start time
and our animation duration.
So here's the meat
of the animation.
So this runnable gets called
every 16 milliseconds while
the animation is in progress.
The t variable is the
portion that we
are through the animation.
And we're also using
an interpolator.
And so these are available
before Ice Cream Sandwich and
Honeycomb as well.
So this is great for like
a accelerate/decelerate
interpolation or a bouncing
interpolation.
And then we just go ahead and
call that set position on the
marker with its new value.
ANKUR KOTWAL: And you'll see
at the end of the handler,
what we do is we re-invoke the
handler after 16 milliseconds.
And of course, that magic number
is used so that we can
get 60 frames per second.
Now one of the downsides to this
is that we are doing this
asynchronously to the Android
UI rendering thread.
So what we can do is use the
property animation framework,
and we're going to shift to the
next one and see in the
value animator how we can
synchronize those.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: OK, so from
Honeycomb onwards, we can use
value animator, as Ankur said.
So here we still have to do
a little bit of setup.
We get the marker's
starting position.
But the value animator can give
us the animated fraction.
So this is the combination of
how far the animation is
through and also the
interpolator.
So any accelerate, decelerate
is applied to that as well.
And so we just again call
set position on that.
ANKUR KOTWAL: So the
onAnimationUpdate override, it
gets invoked as the next frame
is being prepared.
So literally, that's your
opportunity to do whatever
changes you want to make.
And then the frame
will get drawn.
Unlike the handler, which is
just going to happen every 16
milliseconds regardless of when
you're drawing your next
frame, this happens synchronized
with that
rendering framework.
Now the interesting thing is,
or important thing is, you
want to make sure you complete
your execution within 16
milliseconds, otherwise you're
going to miss that draw, and
you're going to get
jank or jitter.
The actual animation of the
value, we're not really using
that, as you can see.
We say ignored.
Because we're animating from
zero to one, but we're not
actually utilizing
that at all.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So let's talk
about Object Animator, which
is also available from
Honeycomb upwards.
But Ice Cream Sandwich
adds some other
nice options, I suppose.
So here we're using an
object animator.
So if you see down on this line,
we just create an object
animator of the marker and
its property position.
We're passing in a type
evaluator, which basically
tells the animation framework
how to animate between custom
object types.
So in this case, it's a latitude
longitude object.
And we just passed in
the final position.
So there's no need to call
marker.getPosition at the
start of the animation,
which is quite nice.
So the type evaluator
is very simple.
In fact, it's very similar to
our lat long interpolator
object, which we'll show you
in the next section.
ANKUR KOTWAL: So the other
advantage that I can see here
is that we've actually got
significantly less code to do
this now than when we started.
So you can obviously
group properties.
You can group different objects
in here as well.
So you can animate things
in bundles.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: This works well
with a property's value
holder, for example.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Yeah.
All right, so that's
animation.
Now let's switch back
to our tablet.
Chris, why don't you walk us
through the next problem?
CHRIS BROADFOOT: OK, so our
animation is very simple.
We're just animating the
latitude and longitude values
of the lat long object
separately.
So this has some problems on
the surface of the earth,
where things wrap around
the date line.
So at the 180th longitude, it's
actually the same point
as minus 180 longitude.
So you'll notice if we try to
animate across, the marker's
going to go all the way around
the world instead of taking
the shortest path.
So we can fix this
very simply.
Let's go over to the code.
So here's our broken
interpolator.
It just takes the lat and
long and takes a linear
interpolation of each value.
And our fixed one just figures
out whether we should take a
shorter path or not.
So it just sees if the distance
it needs to travel is
more than 180 degrees.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Let's switch back
to the tablet and just
see what happens there.
So this is the broken one.
We're traveling around
the world to get to
that shortest distance.
If we just switched to our fixed
one, you'll notice that
we get that path.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah.
So it's very simple.
So you may notice that the
marker doesn't exactly follow
this polyline that we've
added to the map.
So the polyline that we're using
has a geodesic property,
which means that it's taking
the shortest path on the
surface of the earth, as opposed
to a straight line on
the surface of the map.
So if we wanted our marker to
follow the polyline, we can
use similar spherical
mathematics to do this
interpolation instead.
ANKUR KOTWAL: So switching
back to the laptop.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yeah,
so this one's
quite a bit more complex.
You probably won't be writing
this function yourself.
Instead you should probably
just copy and paste it or
include the Android Maps
Utils Library.
But basically, it just does
this spherical math.
So if we switch back
to the tablet--
ANKUR KOTWAL: Here it is broken,
just to show you that
it's actually not following
that line.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yep.
ANKUR KOTWAL: And let's
switch to spherical.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Yup.
So let's go near the poles,
for example, where this is
more obvious.
So you can see there's
quite a large bow.
And the marker's following
the line exactly.
ANKUR KOTWAL: And if we go back
to the broken one, you'll
see that it literally--
CHRIS BROADFOOT: Line goes
straight across.
So the spherical method is very
useful if you want this
marker to follow a line, like
we are here, or if your
markers have some sort of actual
geographic importance,
like perhaps a plane on the map
or something like that.
Just animating the latitude and
longitude separately is
fine for short distances, or if
you don't really care about
any geographic properties, and
is probably quite a bit faster
than the spherical methods.
There's a lot of
maths in there.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Yup, so please
do check out the code
that we have here.
We'll put an annotation
into the video.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: It's going
to be on Ankur's face.
ANKUR KOTWAL: And we hope
you found this useful.